le plus jeunes spectateurs de la tribune
nolan à six semaines les deux loups voir
le normand hamel katell son papa il
soutient déjà à sa manière il avait fait
renaître son papa c'est ça ma 4l
participe à ses premiers jeux
pour lui c'est l'occasion de faire
découvrir sa passion même si le public
se fait un peu désirer
on regrette un peu par quel bout alors
que les dresseurs il s'attendre après
bon c'est un peu le bazar dans la
billetterie tout je pense qu'il ya eu
quelques problèmes de gestion par
rapport à ça les tribunes sont pas sont
pas comblés après on est super contents
d'être d'être ici et de et de faire
parce qu'on sait faire puisque les gens
connaissent pas trop atroce ils se
remplissent doucement en fonction du
temps et entre nos rayons de soleil on
découvre un public éclectique composé de
passionnés venus de loin certes mais
aussi les voisins curieux qui
expérimentent les gens c'est très
intéressant se connaissaient pas du tout
et on découvre elle est vraiment plaisir
ils sont un très haut niveau avec un
handicap surmonter leur handicap
pour moi c'est formidable je suis très
admirative moi aussi une souris un
câblier des parades à sage et nous
voulons voir le niveau des câbliers
internationaux et nous avons vu quel
niveau c'est très récent et vous pouvez
encore en profiter jusqu'à vendredi mais
reste quelques places vendues 5 euros
alors un petit conseil venir trop drôle
une heure avant le début des épreuves et
ainsi vous ne supporte pas hostile